aus sicht wird dass sie nicht blicken
münster in westfalen der st paulus dom
und das rathaus mit seinem friedenssaal
sind bekannte wahrzeichen der stadt
münster ist aber auch bekannt für seine
vielen studenten und für die zahlreichen
fahrradfahrer
viele einwohner der stadt sind politisch
engagiert wie bernd drücke der in einem
alternativen wohnprojekt lebte die aber
darauf an dass lebende künstler viele
aktivisten
ich habe krieg dann wollte ich euch
überreicht gestaltet die titelseite der
zeitung graswurzelrevolution redakteur
bernd muss mit eurer arbeit zufrieden
sein
das neu gestaltete darstellung des
bundes ist dann mal sehen was das
wohnprojekt zu bieten hat
da kommt eigentlich aus rostock und hat
schon zu ddr zeiten war das also gab's
halt würde war schon war schon und die
lieder haben die so eine politische kurs
oder die hört ja wir können ein bisschen
vielen spielen
bank musik gefällt den dreien aber was
gibt's noch singen oder ist sagen und
das ist ein sehr kurzes ich kaufe ein
stelle sind den schrank nenne ihn
schlagen
1 a feld heraus ich habe es auch schecks
in die großen tasche wenn er/sie hasen
taschen und habe wieder eine zu viel
beim nächsten feuerwerk werde ich es in
die luft werfen in meinem jubel
kundzutun
warum soll zum abschluss zeigt bernd
ihnen das blockheizkraftwerk dass sich
im keller des hauses befindet das
wohnprojekt produziert nämlich seinen
eigenen strom
vereinzelte preiswerten
praktisch kaum gekauft sozusagen
und das heißt wir den strom den wir hier
produzieren wer ist also viel viel
günstiger als wenn du jetzt über strom
kaufen wird macht es natürlich mit 60
leute von einer tiefen
es gibt auch konflikte
natürlich auch in höchst werden dass es
manchmal sehr anstrengend aber
ich glaube ich kann mir nichts besseres
nur
anderes ist als wenn man isoliert an
einem grob autoren keiner sind geheim
und dem fahrstuhl hier überall ein
hier ist schon auch eine mannschaft
geben
man kommt immer dann einspringen zu
können das den flyer umsetzen und frohes
schaffen machen alles baum zeigen und
alles auch gegen basel
eric nicole und an moderner machen sich
jetzt ihre eigenen gedanken zum thema
alternatives leben aber werden ihre
ergebnisse redakteur bernd überzeugen
ich habe lukas über die rassismus und
dass bewerber zum denken das heim ist um
sie dann legen also ich bin ihr habt
diese gebrochen
das war schon lange 18 ich hab das
einfach alles
damit für team nord wieder mit 6 zu 5
das ist mein pass auf den umwelt auf
aber ich finde es nicht so typisch dass
man liebt mit so vielen anderen in einer
es aber hier ist das irgendwie alles
gemischt und das wenig sagen was anders
si